Sous Titres : Cassandre COMES
Ça fait un an et demi que je travaille sur un projet top secret...
Pas si secret que ça parce que j'en ai déjà parlé quelques fois.
Mais je peux enfin vous en parler concrètement :
Ma toute première BD que j'ai créée est enfin sortie !
Woaw !
Elle sent bon en plus...
Alors je sais ça fait beaucoup d'infos à digérer.
Quoi ? Cyprien fait une BD ?
Elle est déjà sortie en plus !
Quoi ? C'est déjà l'heure de manger ?
Ça s'appelle "Roger et ses humains", j'ai inventé et écrit toute l'histoire et les personnages
et c'est l'excellent Paka qui a fait les dessins
et la formidable Marie Ecarlat qui a fait toute la couleur.
Oui vous le savez je dessine depuis que je suis tout gamin,
mais non c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui a fait les dessins pour deux raisons.
Raison n°1 :
Eh ben ça demande beaucoup de temps et malheureusement je manque de temps pour dessiner,
c'est le plus long d'ailleurs. Et deux, j'ai toujours voulu collaborer avec Paka
et je me suis dit que c'était l'occasion de faire cette collaboration
et je dessinerais peut-être ma propre BD une prochaine fois sur une autre histoire.
Comme je sais que vous avez beaucoup de questions,
je vais faire une conférence de presse.
Bonjour, merci.
Merci d'être venus aussi nombreux.
On va commencer avec la première question, oui monsieur ?
Oui bonjour, Antoine Karachi, Rien Magazine.
Euh, déjà je trouve très séduisant.
Merci
Alors ma première question c'est... de quoi parle votre BD ?
Alors ça s'appelle "Roger et ses humains" et c'est l'histoire d'un jeune glandeur
et de sa copine qui découvrent un robot chez eux, on sait pas d'où il vient,
et ça va changer leur vie ils vont
vivre plein d'aventures ensemble.
Ce sont des strips de trois quatre cases comme ça, mais avec une histoire qui avance tout le long du livre
Ah, c'est pas une BD Cyprien ?
Non non non, c'est vraiment une toute
nouvelle histoire que que j'ai inventée
avec des nouveaux personnages, je me mets en scène suffisamment souvent dans mes vidéos
donc là je voulais vraiment imaginer quelque chose d'autre.
Bonjour, Nathalie pour Glam's.
J'ai pas compris pourquoi c'est pas vous qui avez dessiné la BD, en fait.
Alors, comme je l'ai dit plus tôt,
je voulais vraiment collaborer avec un dessinateur, spécialement Paka parce que j'adore son style,
et ça m'aurait pris vraiment beaucoup de temps de dessiner tout par moi-même.
D'accord.
Je pense que j'aurais pas fait de vidéos pendant genre six ou huit mois.
Ah oui, non non, ça on veut pas ! Non, non non.
Oui, Clément Bircal, Robot Magazine, bonjour.
Pourquoi avoir choisi un robot comme personnage principal exactement ?
Alors, j'ai eu l'idée de cette BD après avoir vu le film "Her" de Spike Jonze,
qui raconte l'histoire d'amour entre un homme et un système d'exploitation
et en fait je trouvais le sujet passionnant et potentiellement très très drôle donc, pendant le film,
j'écrivais déjà des strips, des idées de vannes
j'ai présenté ça à Paka
il a ri, et puis voilà, le projet était lancé
Lancé...
Ouais, bonjour, Gonzalez, Rapide Magazine.
Est-ce que c'est rapide à faire une BD, c'est rapide ou c'est pas rapide ?
D'accord, euh, déjà prenez un verre d'eau, prenez un verre d'eau pour commencer...
Ah, c'est bon !
Voilà, euh, c'est long, non c'est long à faire, déjà à imaginer,
ça prend du temps parce que c'est quand même toute une aventure avec une dizaine de personnages,
il y a des vannes, j'ai aussi mes vidéos et mes court-métrages à côté et c'est long à dessiner.
Il faut savoir que la première manche de Roger à été dessinée en novembre 2014
donc ça fait tout juste un an.
John Minotti, C'est nul Mag. C'est encore une BD pour les enfants, pour les morveux, c'est ça non ?
Les personnages sont des jeunes
adultes en fait,
ça parle d'Internet, de chômage, de couple,
donc je pense vraiment que ça s'adresse à tout le monde en fait.
Ouais, tout le monde, tout le monde qui a un enfant en fait ?
A tout le monde, ça s'adresse à tout le monde, même les adultes.
Pour les tous petits enfants...
Moins de six mois je mettrais à peu près.
Moi c'est Réno, Action Magazine, Action Mag, le plus grand de tous les héros.
On veut savoir s'il y a de l'action dans "Roger et ses humains".
Ah bah très bonne question de... Renaud ?
Réno
Comme Jean Réno ?
Mais sans le Jean.
Sans le Jean.
D'accord, oui très bonne question, oui il y a de l'action dans "Roger et ses humains"
et alors il y a une partie qui sous
forme de strips et il y a aussi une partie qui est vraiment
sous forme de planches avec de l'action.
D'accord.
Je vous dévoile pas ce qui s'y passe, je vous laisserai découvrir, mais ouais ça bouge pas mal.
Ouais je vois l'idée, ça serait bien que ça se mette un peu sur la gueule hein, ça fait toujours plaisir,
une petite patate comme ça, par ci par là, on va pas se mentir.
La dame.
(question incompréhensible)
J'ai pas entendu en fait, je comprends pas. Vous pouvez pas parler plus fort s'il vous plaît ?
Je ne comprends pas. Est-ce que quelqu'un a compris ?
Elle dit "Est-ce que Roger va avoir une amoureuse ?", c'est ça ?
Oui !
Ah d'accord, euh non pas du tout. Roger est un robot, il n'a pas de... Non non pas du tout,
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a un couple.
Les propriétaires de Roger sont en couple, donc il y a toute une histoire de couple autour de ça.
(question incompréhensible)
Non, là je ne comprends plus...
Théodore Bonnet, Suite Mag. Il y aura une suite ?
Ah bah si vous regardez bien le livre, sur la tranche il y a un petit 1,
ce qui veut dire que c'est le tome 1, donc qu'il va y avoir...
Ouais ! Moi je sais ! Moi je sais !
Un tome 2 !
Exactement !
Yes ! Yes ! Je le savais !
Ah ça fait du bien !
Aurélie, Mag Mag.
Ça fait quoi d'avoir sa propre BD
entre les mains ?
Bah c'est un truc de fou,
c'est un truc de fou parce que je lis
des BD, des tonnes et des tonnes de BD
et de mangas depuis que je suis gamin et je rêvais même quand j'étais gamin de devenir
dessinateur de BD, et finalement des gens m'ont fait confiance et voilà,
je suis devenu auteur d'une BD,
donc ça me touche énormément d'avoir cet objet dans les mains, tout simplement.
Tarik Sedak, Rêve Magazine.
Vous vous êtes fait connaître tout seul sur Internet et aujourd'hui vous réalisez des choses qui vous tiennent à coeur,
c'est quoi votre message pour les jeunes, c'est finalement de...
de croire en ses rêves ?
Nan.
Acheter ma BD.
(musique)